Yonsei continues her reign as the queen  of maternity fashion this time serving  up this red-hot Poston Heritage dress be  rocked the deep V flowy crepe gown at a  private dinner with hubby jay-z and dj  khaled the world is anxiously awaiting  the arrival of those twins but Beyonce  has been so lay in her baby bump fashion  who can forget her not one but two looks  at the Grammys and even though she  didn't attend the Oscars Beyonce still  stole the show at an after-party in this  figure hugging emerald green gown Queen  Bee rocked the gem tone again at the  Beauty and the Beast premiere with her  mini-me Blue Ivy but whether it's  courtside at the NBA all-star game or  Easter Sunday with Mama Tina and Kelly  Rowland Beyonce's pregnancy style has  been in a word  [Music]